should i play this
this is one of the most vile callers we
have take a listen to the i have not
pre-screened this so i
let me just warn you this may not be
suitable for children for children
hey little prickles now that your uh
your
hero is there are you going to sit there
in your little kimono
and wear your little hat rice
because it's going to be called no free
speech
red chinese communist speech
but you can't have pork because you
might offend the ayatollahs
after all they're going to love this too
they're going to make a bomb and i hope
they drop it right on your freaking ass
but you can't have pork but you can't
have pork
you can't have pork just stick that
microphone right up your ass
[Music]
this is highly triggered this is an
extremely triggered
[Music]
[Music]
stay in there
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
winning
[Music]
winning winning winning
[Music]
i have no name for this caller we could
workshop a name together
okay here we go so this started almost
at the stroke of midnight last night
all right let's take a listen to the
first one this is a new caller we've
never had this one before
new caller alert is this david pac-man
i just want to inform you that is this
david pac-man
i just want to inform you that you are a
idiot idiot
once again all right welcome everybody
uh we have
a very important announcement on
vaccines from joe biden in
about 30 and 25 minutes um
a lot a lot going on and we are going to
be standing by
for that and many other things i have so
many updates and things to catch up on
with everybody
so good afternoon good evening good
morning good night
wherever it is that you are it's some
time of day
i don't know i do want to say thank you
before we kick it off to some early
subscribers that crazy guy signed up via
twitch
uh cokebot signed up via twitch
vadaret signed up via twitch
and lambda is love signed up via twitch
that's four people appreciate it guys um
okay where where to even start today i
do have updates on yesterday's
um contest we're gonna be gifting 10
subscriptions i have
emote news i have clips
i have voicemails if you want them
what else do i have um
yeah some of them are from troy yorkie
but but i won't play them unless people
want them and almost unanimously people
do not want
troy york voicemails anymore
um let's go to all right let's start
over here
there was another dust up between
rand paul and dr anthony fauci
during today's hearing let's take a
listen to some clips of that even that
no scientific studies have shown
significant numbers of reinfections of
patients
previously infected or previously
vaccinated
what specific studies do you cite to
argue that the
public should be wearing masks well into
2022
i don't think fauci said that i think
fauci said it's possible there would be
masks in 2022
or or maybe not
i'm not sure i understand the connection
of what you're saying about
masks and re-infection we're talking
about people
who have never been infected before
never
telling everybody to wear a mask whether
they've had an infection or a vaccine
what i'm saying is they have immunity
and everybody agrees they have immunity
what studies do you have
that people that have had the vaccine or
have had the infection are spreading the
infection if we're not spreading the
infection
isn't it just theater no it's not a
vaccine and you're wearing two masks
isn't that theater
no that's not here we go again with the
theater let's get down to the facts
okay the studies that you quote from
crotty
and sete
examination of memory immunity which in
their paper they specifically
say this does not necessarily pertain to
the actual protection
it's in vitro in what study can you
point to that show
significant reinfection there are no
studies that show just he's badgering
the witness
let me let me finish the response to
your question if you please
the only theater i see is rand paul
badgering the witness
sorry the other thing is that when you
talk about reinfection
and you don't keep in the concept of
variance
that's an entirely different ballgame
that's a good reason for a mask in the
south
those are other balls all together
african study
conducted by j and j they found that
people who were infected
with wild type and were exposed to the
variant in south africa the 3-5-1
it was as if they had never been
infected before
they had no protection so when you talk
about re-infection
you've got to make sure you're talking
about wild-type i agree with you that
you very likely would have
protection from wild type for at least
six months
if you're infected but we in our country
now have variants that are circulating
significant
he's really insufferable here's another
what study shows significant
re-infection
hospitalization and death after either
natural infection or the vaccine
it doesn't exist there is no evidence
that there are significant re-infections
after vaccine in fact
i don't think we have a hospitalization
in the united states
after the two-week period after the
second vaccination
yeah you have a death in the united
states you're not
hearing what i'm saying about variance
we're talking about
wild type versus variants and now
what proof is there that there are
significant re-infections with
hospitalizations and death
from the variants none in our country
zero
he says in our country well our country
is late to get a lot of these variants
like every aspect of these questions are
so stupid
plus we don't have a prevalent of a
variant yet
there he goes can i finish we're having
117 that's becoming more dominant
policy based on conjecture he doesn't
make policy
no you have the it isn't based on
conjecturians
so you some you want people to wear a
mask for another couple years no you've
been vaccinated
and you parade around in two masks for
show
no you can't get it again there's almost
there's virtually zero
this guy's an [ __ ] huh chance you're
gonna get it and you're telling people
with them that have had the vaccine who
have immunity
you're defying everything we know about
immunity by telling people to wear masks
have been vaccinated
instead you should be saying there is no
science to say we're going to have a
problem
from the large number of people being
vaccinated you want to get rid of
vaccine hesitancy
tell them they wear their mask after
they get the vaccine you want people to
get the vaccine
give them a reward the one kernel of a
good idea here is we should be more
positive about
how effective the vaccines are and that
you can do more things when you're vac
that i that kernel that's not what he's
saying but i do agree with that
instead of telling him that the nanny
state's going to be there for three more
years and you got to wear a mask forever
people don't want to hear it there's no
science behind it well let me just state
for the record that masks are not
theater
masks are protective and we have
community there theater
if you already have immunity you're
wearing a mask to give comfort to others
you're not wearing a mask because of any
sign there is some mask wearing to give
comfort to others like i mean i've said
before
uh oh we have a nasa event we might look
at later like
when i'm out on the bike path outdoors
even before i was vaccinated but even
now
i don't think there's really any reason
that i need to be wearing a mask but why
do i do it i do it because otherwise
people are like oh that guy's not a team
player look at this [ __ ] not wearing
a mask
you know am i going to go up to them and
be like hey you know the truth is like
you re you're not going to get it
outdoors from a vaccinated person who
zooms by you on a bike like i'll just
put the mask on
you know there there is that but these
are this is like
one percent and then 99 of what rand
paul is doing is just
ridiculous and i see people saying no
you can still spread it if you're if
you're vaccinated
yes you you you can um
but the spread is dramatically reduced
and in an outdoor setting
almost no one is getting this in outdoor
settings even unvaccinated okay so we're
talking about you know fractions
of a percent here but again i'm still
doing it i'm still doing it even
i'm doing it to make other people uh
feel like i'm a team player
luke says it's making my blood boil
listening to the idiot argue with fouchy
yeah it's infuriating
justin says how can a doctor be a dunce
grifter these people have no soul
and pepe says why are rich people
targeted for taxes is it simply because
they can afford it seems like punishment
for doing well am i missing something
check out like my hundred clips about
taxation says perhaps rand is confusing
covered masks with kabuki masks from
traditional japanese
no theater that's possible yeah maybe he
literally was talking about theater
performances that's that's conceivable
um okay we're standing by for joe biden
we're standing by for a nasa event
nasa will be doing a hot fire test of
artemis one
that's coming up a little bit later it's
going to be really really great
um oh okay we are in the middle of a
meme contest
i have 10 memberships to give away
thanks to the donations of stacy
the contest is based off of this image i
posted to my instagram a couple of days
ago this is me with the mother lode
a dozen argentinian croissants
we know these as medialunas this has the
world
abuzz debating are these really
argentinian medialunas and you know all
sorts of other
irrelevant things but the contest is
make some kind of photoshop
of this and get it to me by sunday and
then next week we're going to have a
contest now
i'm going to show you guys one example
this is a really good one just to show
people what we're up against here
this is gaucho david
in a uh traditional gaucho outfit
i'm sure this is argentinian alpaca wool
from northwestern argentina
you can see my artwork has also been
replaced with argentinian gaucho
elements this is just a teaser okay
let me tell you guys now what i do need
help with is figuring out how we're
going to run this contest
because i have 10 memberships to give
away now i said if i only get 10 images
everybody gets one i already have
five ten thirteen so already i need some
kind of
way to do this do i do like a tier maker
and do i rank them
is there some system we could use oh
people want one more
okay let me give you one more let's see
what else i've got here
um oh i don't know let's find it i mean
okay here's the st patrick's day themed
one
see if i can get this over here
here's one other one this is so
these are my green croissants you know
yesterday was st
patrick's day so anyway as you can see
the quality
varies dramatically but if you want to
get me one of those if you want to play
send it to info davidpakman.com get it
to me by
sunday and we are going to have yeah
it's like we need some kind of ranked
choice
system i could do a tier list and just
start ranking
the top 10 will get a free membership
thanks to stacy
all right big thank you to lewis gorford
lewis gorford just did something heroic
lewis
went to join pacman.com and got a
membership
using the secret wow louis knows the
secret coupon code
we have this coupon code better21 lewis
just used the code
immoral 21 which is an unpublished
coupon code
alright so thanks to thanks to lewis
also thanks to canned caviar for gifting
a sub
liquid ice has 16 months
asking can a chicken sandwich ever be
considered a burger
i think if you have a grilled chicken
breast on a bun
it's a it's a chicken sandwich i don't
think that's a burger no
so liquid ice and canned caviar also
thanks to bella haired designs it's me
john b
um that's four putting us
five plus four is nine
very much appreciate that
uh other super chats how quickly would
you like to see america surplus vaccines
donated to our neighbors isn't there an
argument to keeping a stockpile for
boosters against variants
we don't have variant booster shots
right now if the
if the goal is to have vaccines for
variants
we need to wait for the vaccines that
are tailored to the variants so
stockpiling the current vaccines for
variants doesn't doesn't make any sense
as therian says a good friend doesn't
want the vaccine out of a friend group
of 50.
the other 49er for it how do i go about
convincing him i don't you know without
knowing more about them i
i wouldn't be able to say when do you
take calls for friday's show typically
wednesdays around noon eastern
um but oh we are doing an extra set of
live calls tomorrow to have more content
for our spring break
vacation uh so we will be doing live
calls an
extra set of live calls tomorrow around
2 45
eastern u.s all right so that'll be
tomorrow
do i have any unban requests none i have
no unban requests at this time
um let's see what else we've got
i have a new manic moderate voicemail
let's listen to that
from lakeland daughter
we're getting ready to go down to mexico
to spend some time you know
down there and some that she get some of
that
inexpensive i know they don't like
saying it's
cheap so it's inexpensive
places to stay down in in mexico
all those evil brown people you know
those
evil brown people was you
is he okay sounds off today
personally i don't give a [ __ ] what
color anybody is we're all getting
[ __ ] you know
just like i hear all this trash about
minorities minorities kids
vote cause they gotta get all deep
let me get let let me get this straight
there david
they have no trouble getting id to buy
beer
they got no trouble getting id to buy
cigarettes
you gotta have id to go in the in the
pot store
you don't need a us id so this i think
is about voting
voter registration um you're allowed to
come to the u.s
with you know a legal mexican id and buy
cigarettes
because you don't need to be a us
citizen to buy cigarettes you just have
to be 18.
you can't register to vote if you're not
a u.s citizen i mean
this is a weird rant so
oh but they they they can't get id to
vote but they can get id to
buy a pot to buy drugs
yeah you don't need to be a citizen for
those things or excuse me
to buy yeah well you do need to show
your idea i even have to show my idea to
pharmacy yeah yeah
right for controlled substances for a
prescription you need to show an idea
to prove who i am but it doesn't have to
be an american id that's the point
damn now certain drugs
yeah but they can't get id
to vote no they're too dumb
[ __ ] they're just all right so there
it is um
we had we had a racist uh message come
through let's see i guess i'll just kind
of go up until it scrolls past
racist super chat the user's been banned
okay so there is that do people want
troy york voicemails i'll put it to a
vote again
the audience has turned completely
against the troy york voicemails i have
two new ones
it's always a no lately but i'll paste
the poll
over on twitch and people can vote i'm
pasting the poll right now on youtube
and people can also vote there i have
two
troy york voicemails but let's see if
people want
every time we take a vote it used to
always be a yes people going against
troy york voicemails more and more and
more been a long time
people just bored with troy york and
that's fine there's you're under no
obligation
to listen to the voicemails i want to
say thanks to zach
kniffen zack just signed up at
joinpackman.com
using the immoral coupon code immoral21
and zach's new member number 10 today i
also want to say thanks to adam david
lee
for subscribing via twitch your new
member number 11.
the votes are ramping up with 165 votes
cast
this one is closer the no's have it as
of right now 52-48
do not want troy york voicemails um i
don't know if this would be
something that would make you want them
or not um
the character troy york called in once
as
troy york and then he called in once
as uh whitaker marshall the third which
is another one of troy york's characters
so
i don't know if that makes it more
appealing or less appealing to people
but those are today's characters with
205 people voting we're still roughly at
52 to 48 against
troy york voicemails i know people are
looking for yes votes
we just you you really only need 10 yes
votes right now to turn this around
maybe
the secretary of state of georgia would
find it for you
jd straight shot as the vote continues
jd straight shot says some people are
saying rand paul's dad and cancun cruz's
dad killed jfk
also got my first modern vaccine side
effects where i wanted to buy microsoft
office pro for 30 minutes and a sore
arm for a day that's not bad
that's not bad daritan says i went to
afghanistan you don't need to display
true heroism and visit joinpakman.com
well said
like the stream youtube watchers says
edward
and charles says have you ever done a
segment about the southern strategy and
conservative argument
about democrats being the real racist
yeah we've talked about that
yeah pepe says f mary kill beaubert
magga nanny and tandon wow
um wow that's really tough
that's really tough oof i i'd have to
think about that
i don't know i think beaubert's getting
killed in that one
probably but that's an aggressive game i
don't know if that game is appropriate
for this
for this channel we have a very tight
race it is down to only a
one vote margin on no for troy york
voicemails
i don't know that it's ever been this
close
should i play two new troy york
voicemails the yeses
oh no the yeses have it now i'm sorry
it's a yes
let's see yes now leading by two votes
oh my goodness
five subs have just been gifted by
carnivan as well that puts us at 16.
also thanks to jessica kybel for
the 17th membership today wow we could
have a stunning
this was it was a it was a no mirage now
the yes votes leading by
three the mail-in votes are being
counted
david is the merch advertised under your
youtube videos legit
yes yes absolutely that's fulfilled by
teespring and it is completely
legitimate
completely legitimate um
we have a tie ladies and gentlemen we
have a tie
on should i play two new troy york
voicemails
i don't know what happens if we have it
and the no is now in the lead again
let's give it i don't know we'll count
the first 350 votes just to
to stop it at a certain point um no now
leading by one vote
with 311 no leading by one vote with 313
tai with 316
yes leading with 319
tai with 320. tie with 322
i posted the links earlier guys
yes takes the lead by three with 329
we're going to 350.
yes now winning by 5 at 3 31.
where is odd oh here sorry yeah i keep
refresh that's i'm so stupid i didn't
realize that
yes now pulling away yes is plus eight
coming from behind very very strongly
although no catching up a little bit and
pulling within eight
now it is within seven with only seven
votes to go two votes to go we're
calling it at 350
calling it at 350 plus five and it's
over
with 353 yeses in the lead yes is in the
lead we could have listened to both both
voicemails by now yeah
you guys are absolutely right all right
let's uh i'll just play them real quick
the yes is one i know that there's been
a lot of defeats for troy york but let's
listen
once again it's total evidence that you
are a hack in the show
for joe biden and the democrat party
the right-wing media has been
eviscerating
joe biden especially after that
ridiculous 17-minute little speech
where he told us that we had to obey his
orders
otherwise we couldn't celebrate the
fourth of july he never said it i'm
already bored
i never said i was going to play the
whole thing here's another troy york
voicemail
hi david pakman this is troy york
calling in
basically to counter what you were
talking about
cancel culture and um without any
evidence
to back yourself up you say that
uh you found it interesting that
republicans
and fox news were fans of fox news
anybody else keyed into this like it's
actually gotten really boring
i'm not sure exactly uh what you said
but
he doesn't know what i said you said
that they but he has a really strong
push back to it
surprised that they're into literature
and
um they don't read a book what what
evidence do you have that fox listeners
have not um
[Music]
fox viewers have not read a book
a lot of yes voters want their vote back
asking to take back their yes vote i
understand guys since grammar school or
high school
and uh doesn't that comment you i don't
know if you ever look at yourself in the
mirror you probably don't
or listen to your own podcast but that's
that's max or believism
and it just shows what a total dip [ __ ]
you are
uh all right anyway i'm pretty bored
with it all but the yes is one
and you got what you wanted and now
we're done
okay pepe xanadu says is troy york
you're jeff the boar from the howard
stern show in a sense
in a sense thanks to matthew garman
matthew garman just signed up with the
immoral coupon code
immoral 21 a secret unpublished coupon
code and his new member number 18.
i also want to say thanks to slingblade
for 14 months on twitch
and razzle dazz for their first month on
twitch that puts us at 20.
okay let me do some twitch housekeeping
if i can
guys i have emote updates today i had
delivered to me
a new emote for twitch it is david
uh it's a bitcoin one where i have laser
eyes it's pending approval
um i think it's david11p
bitcoin or something like that it came
to me from our moderator green man but i
think
nug wrangler might have made it in any
case
i took away the uh ideas
bulb because that one is kind of lame
and i've replaced it with david
p david p11 bitcoin i think it is
it'll be approved soon now
there's all sorts of requests for new
emotes so right now
i have five slots for different
uh tiers i think oh god this is gonna be
a
i don't even understand like what's
going on but let me figure out exactly
what i have right now
because i know that people want more
uh hold on a second
where where is this followers
stream summary moderation emotes okay
so let me tell you what's available i
have five available for bit
cheerers okay at the 1000 bits level we
have 81 people who would get to use that
5 000 bits is 13 ten thousand bits is
nine people
twenty five thousand bits is two people
and nobody at fifty thousand bits
if we get to someone donating a total of
fifty thousand bits we will get another
emote at seventy five thousand bits
right now the closest to 50k
inconsolable has done 28
000 bits rjc has done 25
000 bits and odwd that that one
has done 15 000 bits okay so right now i
have
five slots we may get to a sixth one
okay so if people have emotes for me
i i would love emotes info
davidpakman.com they must be
square and under one megabyte and i
think transparent backgrounds are good
okay so let's get it going i i don't
i'm glad to add more emotes is the point
but i just need to know what people want
they should be related to the show like
random emotes
you know like you know biden or whatever
i don't
i think they should be related to the
show and right now i have five that i
can take on
and if ever we get to a 50 000 bit
donor i will have a sixth that we can
take on all right so that's
housekeeping as far as that goes
um what else did i have
um oh oh oh
here's something that i think is
fascinating i
love scams this is an interesting
channel
carl rock he exposes scams i watched
this earlier some of you may find this
interesting this is
so many countries there's taxi scams in
argentina it's filled with taxi scams
and i'm familiar with them
here's karl rock exposing the taxi scams
in uh i believe this is in new delhi to
check this out i love stuff like this
main market any hotel no main market
in india yeah first time
how much is it they go there just only
[Music]
i'll
[Music]
[Music]
now we're down to a thousand i think
it's too expensive stuff
surprised that it's a company
the company car is a thousand okay no
it's okay thank you
this is a good price where are you
new zealand so i tell you how many days
you always tell me a good price eh it is
this good price
amazing price yes just otherwise one
thousand eight hundred
prices right other people will charge
you 18. i offered you 12 but i'll do it
for a thousand
really 1800 but i will give you a
reasonable price because you tell me
yeah this guy he told them this thing so
you get a better price
[Music]
go with this guy this guy will do it for
600. who's this guy we have no idea why
this guy only charges 600 maybe the car
something's wrong with the car i don't
know
[Music]
you give him 600 feet a third guy now
he will give you 600 feet coming from
i don't know
[Music]
this is common in argentina too which is
like just kind of like oh let's go let's
go let's get going yeah
how much is it
this is the pre-paid taxi booth right
outside gate two
let's see how much bahari ganja is from
here how much is bahadur ganj
400 400 okay all right so 400 rupees
there
this is very common in a lot of
countries and um
uh many many travelers have been exposed
to that the guy has some interesting
videos he gets so he deliberately gets
sold some fake
cashmere in another video and
um yeah i actually did get scammed
um i want to i don't want to make this
any kind of racial thing in any way so
i'm just going to tell the story in the
most kind of like
sterile way possible in milan
italy i um was scammed
on my first a subway ride
where i was looking at the you know
every every place has different machines
to buy subway tickets
and i um wanted to use a credit card and
someone
very quickly came up and said oh i can
help you the credit card's not working
you have to use cash and of course the
credit card was working fine
and they helped me to get a ticket but
then took the change and said this is
for me for helping and before i knew it
i was out 10 euro for two dollars worth
of subway passes
you know it was then after that i was
like the credit card thing is always
working and i don't need anyone's help
that was like 12 years ago
and now i don't accept any help getting
a uh
a subway pass you live you learn
you live you learn jess morgan has just
signed up at joinpackman.com
using the coupon code immoral21
and is actually new member number 21
today
i also want to say thanks to j.e sanci
for the twitch prime sub as well as
king arthur
razzle dazzle and slingblade
that's four somebody's requesting a
massive
dumps emote yeah we could do that as
long as it's
you know not rancid but yeah i'm open
for that
um a lot of people think that the coupon
codes on my website are scams but they
no they're really it's really that cheap
the discount codes are really that good
why does legalization of drugs differ
from guns
other than they are different things
doesn't gun restrict
give power to black market like coke and
cartels
i don't know that i understand this
completely chris
and i have to think about that a little
bit karl rock
broke up a scam with jim browning
interesting
i was really hoping denying his calls
would make troy york step up his game
sadly he remains shallow and pedantic
sad troy
sad yeah his voicemails are getting
worse
david play voicemail from vega from
oklahoma yeah no i don't we're not doing
any more voicemails right now
but we review all voicemails
all voicemails of course uh
and send appropriate ones to the
authorities as always
methos mint says it's funny if trump
lied and said he took the vaccine
to prove it was safe for trump's they'd
take it and he'd improve his ratings but
too obsessed with looking weak no we've
learned trump has now taken the vaccine
and he actually said in an interview
with maria bartoromo earlier this week
that people should get it he he said it
trump now has uh has said that
um people asking for unbanned requests i
still have
no unbe just people aren't it seems
everybody we're banning knows they
should be banned
let's see who's been banned recently
someone who goes by the name
david s pakman was banned for
impersonation and for saying
david spaz libtard stream that's a good
that's a good ban
i i can i'm behind that
um joe biden is a house plant
xenophobic you are an effing idiot they
were banned
okay i'm just looking at recent bans
joe biden is a deep fake he's not alive
um 100 of border crossers are felons
these border crossing children are the
same as murderers they were banned
okay let's see who else
yeah a lot of people get it's sad what
people do i imagine that
everybody getting banned are little kids
but there's probably some adults who do
this stuff
um happy international women's day
i'll get the goddamn laundry done they
were banned
they also said hi david i'm david pakman
please watch me regurgitate propaganda
that's a pretty good ban i mean if they
had a good case for an unban
i would entertain it but that's a pretty
good i'm seeing all good bands
um yeah nothing else notable here
no one here can prove covet 19 exists
they were banned instantly
oh i banned them oh that's good i'm i
agree i completely agree with the fact
that i banned that person
yeah so the it's these are very solid
bands very these are
these are unlikely to be you know it's
sort of like when police bring a case
and the prosecutor decides whether to go
forward
you're already thinking of appeals you
don't want to end up losing you don't
want to go through the trouble
of prosecuting a case and then you it
gets overturned on appeal
i feel good on about all of these these
are these are unlikely to be reversed by
an adjudicator like me i want to say
thanks to cody manharth
cody just signed up at joinedpakman.com
with the coupon code
immoral21 if people are wondering about
this
we have a published coupon code better21
and it's like
okay it's sort of like it's off-putting
it's an off-putting coupon code but it's
not immoral
we created an unpublished coupon code a
couple streams ago
immoral 21 it's not published anyone
it's huge and it is completely immoral
and people are taking advantage of it
right now
um and it's available to you as well
show us the gavel oh yeah i have the
gavel here but there's nothing to
adjudicate right now
chakaseki says i used the borderline
illegal coupon code
doge21 and now my browser is asking me
for 10
000 dogecoin or doji coin as it was once
said during a
congressional testimony to unlock my
computer is this a scam
yes that's absolutely a scam
don't do not fall for that chakaseki
chris says sorry for being confusing it
seems like the argument for making drugs
legal
is opposite to restricting guns wouldn't
it give power to cartels
no i i don't even know why we would
evaluate guns
gun laws and drug laws the same in the
same way because we're talking about two
very different things one which is
treated as a criminal issue
which is really a health issue the other
which is an item used to commit violent
crime and i know the the ways in which
guns
relate to illegal drugs i i'm just not
seeing it exactly the way you are chris
with with total respect um
yeah i'm just i'm just not sure about
that not sure about that
uh there is a nasa event starting soon
which looks very interesting there's
going to be a hot fire test for the
artemis moon rocket but we are standing
by for joe biden
who should be starting momentarily with
a really big
vaccine announcement latest vaccine
numbers by the way
let's refresh
latest vaccine numbers are we are at we
are
so close we are now at 2.47
million doses per day getting really
close to 2.5
and um we need to continue we need to
continue accelerating because we're
actually no longer seeing
the the trickle down in cases so
the rapid decline in cases that you saw
here
has slowed down we're basically
horizontal we've been at 55
000 cases a day now for a little bit so
we've got to keep working on vaccination
and then um deaths fortunately have been
declining more quickly
and hopefully they will continue to
decline but we need to do more
and what's crazy is that if you look
globally cases are going up globally
check this out this is global cases
they bottomed out at 360
360 000 a day and now they're all the
way back up to 450 a day
and globally deaths are still declining
but they're sort of starting to level
out as well so europe's having a problem
look at what's going on in brazil
it's nutty what is going on and look at
this
brazil is as bad as it's ever been
that's cases in brazil let's look at
deaths death certs look at
look at this the worst days in brazil
were yesterday and the day before
it's nuts what is going on there
and people are demanding i look at the
uk numbers all right i'll do that
uk let's see what's going on in the uk
uk numbers are looking good
uk numbers are looking very good
uh and let's see yeah uk is looking
really good really really good
so we're going to continue watching all
of those numbers but vaccination must
continue must must continue oh sorry
italy yeah
i'm hearing italy's in trouble but i
haven't yet uh
italy there it is whoa
let's look at italy
oh yeah italy is accelerating they're
almost back up to their worst peak
remember when we thought this was bad
back in march
and then we got to this and then italy
is once again accelerating now
the rate of acceleration the first
derivative of these numbers is actually
declining
um the rate of growth is declining hey
folks oh
good to see you all when i announced
in early december that had a goal
that i set of administering 100 million
shots for the virus in the first
100 days right of our office 100 million
shots in 100 days
it was considered ambitious some even
suggested was somewhat audacious
wasn't really that expert said that it
was uh
the plan was quote definitely aggressive
and distribution would have to be
seamless
for us to be successful not exactly one
headline
simply put it quote it won't be easy
end of quote well it wasn't
when i took office when we took office
there was a lot
that had to be done we needed more
vaccines
more vaccinators more places for people
to get
vaccinated all true and we needed a
whole government approach
so i directed jeff science the
coordinator of our
covent 19 response to put us on a war
footing and i meant that in a literal
sense to get us on track to truly
beat this virus i love that to announce
58 days into our administration we will
have met
my goal of ministering 100 million shots
wow to our fellow americans
that's weeks ahead of schedule right and
even with the setbacks we face during
the winter storms
and there's another big step on the path
to checking
the putting checks in pockets and shots
in people's arms
when we cross the 50 million doses just
three weeks ago
i told you that every time we hit the 50
million mark
i'd update you on our progress so here's
where we are today
please eight weeks ago only eight
percent of seniors
those most vulnerable to cova 19 had
received a vaccination
today 65 percent
of people aged 65 or older have received
at least
one shot and 36 percent are fully
vaccinated
and that's key because this is the
population that represents
80 percent of the well over 500 000 cova
19
deaths that have occurred in america we
have nearly double the amount of vaccine
doses that we distribute to states
tribes and territories each week we have
gone
from one million shots a day that i
promised in december
before we're even sworn in to an average
of two and one-half million shots a day
right outpacing the rest of the world
significantly
and here's how we accomplish this
using the power given to a president
under the defense production act
we expedited critical materials in
vaccine production
such as equipment machinery and supplies
we work with vaccine manufacturers to
speed up the delivery of millions more
doses
and brokered a historic manufacturing
partnership
between competing companies who put
patriotism on public health first
these steps put us on track to have
enough vaccine enough vaccine supply
for every adult american by the end of
may
that's huge months months earlier than
anyone expected
and we stood up or supplied more than
600 community vaccination sites
that are administering hundreds of
thousands of shots per day
we launched the federal pharmacy program
which has allowed millions of americans
to get a shot at one of one thousand or
extremely
one of 14 000 local pharmacies in this
country
the same way they get their flu shot
and for folks who aren't near pharmacy
or mass
vaccination center we've supplied more
than
500 mobile clinics like pop-up sites or
vans
meeting people where they are meeting
people where they are
we've developed nearly we deployed
nearly 6 000
federal personnel including fema
active duty military and department of
health and human services to support
vaccinations and serve as vaccinators
putting the needle in people's arms
we're also supplying vaccines to
community health centers
to reach those who have been the hardest
hit
the hardest hit and suffered the most
especially black latino native american
and rural communities
this is really important because we
believe that speed and efficiency
must be matched with fairness and equity
now when president harris and i took a
virtual tour of a vaccination center in
arizona
not long ago one of the nurses
on that on that tour injecting people
giving vaccinations
said that each shot
was like administering a dose of hope
a dose of hope that's how she phrased it
behind these 100 million shots
are millions of lives changed when
people receive that dose of hope
grandparents can hug their grandchildren
again front line workers
who can show up at their jobs without
the same fear they used to have
teachers with the confidence to head
back into the classroom
these milestones are significant
accomplishments
but we have much more to do
much more to do and the american rescue
plan will help us do it
in addition to the cash payments it
provides to you and your families it
also provides
the funds to add vaccinators to supply
more community vaccinations support more
community vaccination
centers and increase testing
it'll help us accelerate nationwide
efforts to reopen our schools safely
and as i told the nation last week i've
directed all states
tribes and territories right to make all
adults eligible to be vaccinated
no later than may the first many states
going more quickly i'm glad to see that
several states
are already taking that step there it is
to make more and more americans eligible
even before may 1st tomorrow
we will hit 100 million doses our
administration has administered
but i've always said that's just the
floor
we will not stop until we beat this
pandemic
next week i'll announce our next goal
to put shots in arms this
is a time for optimism all right but
it's not a time for relaxation
i need all americans i need all of you
to do your part
wash your hands stay socially distanced
keep masking up as recommended by the
cdc
and get vaccinated when it's your turn
now's not the time to let down our guard
in the last week we've seen increases in
the number of cases in several states
scientists have made clear that things
may get worse
as new variants of this virus spread
getting vaccinated is the best thing we
can do to fight back against these
variants
while millions of people are vaccinated
we need millions
more to be vaccinated and again
i need you to get vaccinated when it
comes when you're your term and you're
able to do that
i need your help i need you to help
not just the country but your family
your friends your neighbors
get them vaccinated as well if we keep
our guard up
stick together and stick with the
science
we can look forward to a fourth of july
that feels a bit more normal
with small groups able to gather for
cookouts in backyards
and when we be where we begin to declare
our independence
on independence day from the virus look
together
together we're going to come through
this stronger with renewed faith in each
other
and our government that fulfills this
most important function
protecting the american people let me be
clear again
wearing this mask in the meantime
making sure you wash your hands making
sure you socially distance
listen to the cdc we've got to reach the
point
where we have herd immunity meaning
where we have a vast
majority of the american people have
been vaccinated before we can stop
wearing these
so please please don't let what happened
you see happening in europe and you see
on television
keep the faith keep wearing the mask
keep washing your hands and keep
socially distance
we're going to beat this we're way ahead
of schedule
but we got a long way to go i just
wanted to bring you up to date i thank
you very much and may
god bless america may god protect our
troops thank you so much
some questions there about vladimir
putin
not answered today by joe biden but
certainly uh he is going to be answering
the hell this went to some kind of
gaming stream back to home sweet home
what on earth is this
this is what it went to after the biden
event
we got some floaters but that's not what
we were talking about what's this thing
man i don't know what's going on
all right so that's that um so joe biden
delivering uh remarks on uh vaccination
okay so next week next week joe biden
will be holding a press conference on
thursday i will be covering it and joe
biden also may be doing i guess another
event with new
goals and on vaccination and we will
cover that
as well i do want to say thank you to
kevin dobbs for signing up at
joinpackman.com
as well as evan peterson and lastly
marika edwards
uh thanks to the three of you also
thanks to lynn
53 for the twitch prime sub
very very much appreciate that biden
misspoken said president harris as
people are telling me
uh and and fox news is going to go nuts
of course they are
of course they are but i'm trying not to
uh play uh
play too much into it reminder tomorrow
2 45 p.m eastern we are recording extra
live calls because we're going to be on
break after next week we want to have
extra content to publish to youtube and
various platforms so if you want to get
on the phone with me tomorrow it'll be
via discord as usual davidpakman.com
slash discord 2 45 pm
eastern u.s time tomorrow okay that's
about
23 hours from now very very
important all right thanks everybody for
joining me we will be back with so much
soon get me the emotes
get me the emotes very important